yeah they're doing you know they're
doing a han Solo solo film the shooting
one right now you're aware of this
I wonder if an obi-wan kenobe a solo
rock you know that only obi-wan is that
something that you would be interested
that's a good title only overall Naomi
yeah I would I it's got to the point
where I'd be not enough don't mean any
offense no I mean I just questioned so
many times and I answer questions yeah
when I'm asked them because I've been
probably that yeah it's polite I am and
it's got to the point now where it looks
like I'm toting for work at Disney front
door oh I say give me the hope like you
were saying yeah but I of course I'd be
happy to do it and did you steal a
lightsaber yeah he did that the first
time and where is that lightsaber now
you don't know congratulations everyone
we're finally getting that obi-wan movie
so let's freak out about this there
hasn't been a whole lot of good Star
Wars news lately there's been all the
drama with the Han Solo movie so I feel
like they were announcing this because
they had it in the works for a while and
they're like we need a big win for the
Star Wars universe right now because
they're not quite ready to release
another trailer for last Jedi but they
do have some press and they're throwing
pork that everyone left and right like
senior some porks everybody chill out
so obi-wan movie was the one thing that
everyone's been asking about for the
last couple of years since they
announced the Boba Fett movie which is
still Court of spinning it outer orbits
somewhere it sort of blew up when josh
trank the person who was going to do it
in Fantastic Four blew up in Fox's face
Star Wars is like okay maybe we just put
this on the back burner for a while but
through it all obi-wan had been rumored
and they just put it off because they're
still doing so much original trilogy
stuff in the new saga films so you have
Luke you have Leia you have Han all
these old characters that are coming
back it made sense that they would
include some obi-wan moments and then
wait till after that story is done to do
a full-blown obi-wan movie so they're
not stepping on each other's toes
because the whole idea of the spin-off
films is that you focus on characters
that you wouldn't normally spend an
entire movie focusing on in broaden the
mythology in a way that enriches the
previous movies before like the way they
fill that gap with the Death Star logic
with rogue ones like Oh
they did it on purpose Jin's father
pretended to be on the side of the
Empire in order to give them a big win
and help them destroy it later on so
there's all kinds of stuff that they can
do with this obi-wan movie there's a
giant period of his life that they
haven't explored yet they just needs a
little bit of it on rebels as they sort
of capped off Darth Maul's storyline so
I'll dress like the really big obi-wan
characters that they can deal with in
this movie because like the huts for
instance are very relevant to Han Solo's
character so I'm expecting them to pop
up during that but after episode 3 all
we really know of obi-wan there's even
not a whole lot of comic books or
stories written about him they talk
about those years other than he was
waiting on Tatooine watching Luke from
afar grow up just making sure that he
was safe in trying to help people out in
the area so just looking at the cannon
that they've established so far he went
up against Jabba's men as they tried to
extort people on Tatooine he finally
killed Darth Maul during Star Wars
rebels when Luke was in grade school I
think he was less than about 7 years old
just looking at this picture here they
just want to make it look like he's very
very young so there's a couple options
right off the bat they can do it Obi one
film set before his time with Anakin
when he's really young which I don't
think they're going to do I just think
that would sound like another prequel
pitch like oh we're going to show how he
became a Jedi we're going to over
explain everything mysterious about him
that makes him seem really cool one of
the biggest questions that I've gotten
the last couple days is will you and
McGregor come back and play the
character it should totally go without
saying that of course they're going to
bring him back now the story is up for
grabs like they're probably going to do
something that we haven't seen before
but he is the one constant in like Paul
Rudd he's aging in Reverse so he almost
looks exactly as young as he did when he
originally played the character so the
obi-wan movie subtitles shut up and take
my money just sounds like an easy
slam-dunk anything they do that's even
relatively close to Canon will probably
do gangbusters and what I'm really
hoping they do because there's so many
rebels things that they brought back
from the original trilogy
ahsoka just came back from Clone Wars I
feel like they could bring back a lot of
Clone Wars characters that are still
alive during this period between episode
3 and episode 4 so really you're just
looking at that timeframe so anything
during
what's going on on Star Wars rebels
right now or even after that because
rebels is meant to bridge that gap so
it's like the burst of the rebellion but
you still have some Jedi that are
floating around that haven't been killed
by Darth Vader and the Emperor yet and
you're starting to see the emergence of
the original trilogy characters who were
either very young or in the process of
rising to positions of power like
Princess Leia on Star Wars rebels
they've done Lando Calrissian so the
only thing they really can't do is
introduce characters to each other that
didn't meet before episode 4 so like
obi-wan Kenobi doesn't know who Han Solo
and Chewbacca are before they meet in
the cantina so I'm not expecting those
characters to pop up so just gauge your
expectations based on that but Rex for
example big Clone Wars characters that
they then turned into a big rebels
character and then just recently a Star
Wars Celebration canonized as this
person during the Battle of Endor
so because Rex is still alive during
episode 6 that means that he could be in
the obi-wan movie and it wouldn't break
canon so we've been dancing around this
but obviously the other big one is
ahsoka I feel like if they're going to
bring her back in the live-action movies
obi-wan is an awesome movie to do that
and because you can do ancillary Darth
Vader stuff she learned during rebels
that Darth Vader is Anakin Skywalker
they had that big faceoff last season
and they sort of left her hanging in the
air like they make you wonder if she's
still alive is she dead
purty be logic of course she's still
alive and she'll come back in some big
twist and everybody screaming oh this is
so awesome the other really cool thing
that they can do to expand the mythology
is dig deeper into the idea of the wills
and their teaching because that's one of
the big things they've been doing with
the new saga films as well as rogue one
particularly with rogue one and then
with the last Jedi which no one has seen
yet but they're teasing out the Journal
of the will so clearly it's a big thing
and most of the big reveals will be
saved for the saga films while obi-wan
was in exile watching over Luke we know
that he communed with the force and
learn how to become a force ghost just
like qui-gon jinn so you can show a
little bit of that but I would shell out
all of my money for a movie with obi-wan
palying around the galaxy with ahsoka
tano in Rex and you can include anybody
else you want from rebels and as long as
you don't step
on the toes of young Luke Skywalker too
much you can show a little bit of
Tatooine as well but I think they want
to keep young Luke out of the movies as
much as possible like there are
something to just feel like too much
like you don't want to turn it into a
prequel thing where you over explain
something that's meant to be this first
big reveal so when we meet them for the
first time in Episode four I think
that's always going to be the first big
time that we see him so while I think
it's okay for movies set before episode
for any spin-off movies to reference him
I think it's just a really smart idea to
try and avoid including a 7 or 8 year
old Luke in any of those movies just it
feel like it would cheapen a lot of
those big episode 4 moments so just
remember you and McGregor sometime
between Episode three in Episode four
any story is pretty much up for grabs
because there's not a whole lot of
obi-wan stories that they've told during
that period outside of him rapping up
darth maul's storyline and because they
already did that on rebels I'm not
expecting to see Darth Maul in any of
the movies but it would be really cool
if they try to bring back Hayden
Christensen for like a very brief moment
like when you see Darth Vader in Empire
Strikes Back with his helmet off for the
first time from the other way around
maybe they included him in a very brief
moment like that but that's it we don't
need a whole bunch of Hayden Christensen
Anakin Skywalker walking around during
the movie but presumably because of the
order they announced these in like Han
Solo will be the movie between Episode
eight in Episode nine Obi one will be
the next movie after Episode nine
so just chart your timeline based on
that but let me know in the comments
just what do you want to see from this
obi-wan movie assuming that Ewan
McGregor is coming back so it's going to
be set between Episode three in Episode
four in which characters do you want
them to include
[Music]
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
watch some of the defenders I'll be
posting more videos for that this
weekend and obviously new Game of
Thrones so while you wait for everything
you can click here for brand new last
Jedi footage and you can click here for
the punisher trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome i'll
see you guys tonight
you